alors comment votre aventure sur les
réseaux sociaux at elle commencé vous
êtes des superstars n'appellera alors
pas au niveau d'olivier rousteing mais
en moins il ya quelques millions
d'abonnés en région a gagné mais comment
vous vous êtes lancé
comment s'est lancée par une marque de
maillots de bain on a lancé notre marque
avant même de lancer nos réseaux ou en
même temps et ça a pris parce que voilà
tout le monde le sait on se montre un
maillot de bain donc forcément ça
accrocheur on a voyagé le monde entier
pour faire la promotion mais devint donc
voilà on a conquis le monde entre
guillemets on est suivi beaucoup aux
états unis dans le monde et voilà ça a
commencé sur landi de créer notre propre
marque de maillots de bain est sorti on
en a sorti un peu moins champions mais
reste elle reste je sais que c'est
compliqué moi je mets ça je ressemble à
un rôti de porc de dimitri je sois je
pensais moi je pense pas mais bravo pour
ce corps non mais c'est vrai que c'est
assez rare d'être moi aussi j'ai essayé
[Applaudissements]
mais quelque chose de paradoxal star des
réseaux sociaux et pourtant c'est votre
première télé on est très flattée que
vous nous réservez cela que je suis
invité à les remercier
mais pourquoi être resté hors du champ
de la télévision j'espère présent
puisqu'on est discrète c'est vrai qu'on
a c'est une vitrine instagram montrent
très discrets
au rex et c'est peut-être mentionné que
marraine de tristane vitrine mais dans
la vie on a une personne nous connais
vraiment on est jumelles donc on est
moins ouverte je pense à ma cause ou
grâce à ça aux gens je parle de deux ans
tant que personnellement là vous ne
connaissez pas personnellement regardant
nos goûts nos photos en personne ne
connaît aussi personnellement
maintenant vous savez personnellement
vous connais pas non car ce n'est pas
personnellement mon attention nous
connaître intimement la ville certains
oui ça reste une image qu'on veut
montrer et ça fonctionne puisque
s'appelait a quand même beaucoup de
monde
maintenant la télé non vous n'avez
jamais eu le besoin et en plus on
appréhendait aussi un peu on était un
peu stressé 6 avant de venir et voilà
c'est notre première télé maintenant on
avait envie de parler de vous montrer
pourquoi on fait ça vous dire pourquoi
on fait ça et pourquoi on a autant suivi
on a pas on assume qui en est ça veut
pas dire qu'on est on sera mal pas envie
qu'il y ait dans la rue tous les jours
et pourquoi pas oui en confiance bien
sûr oui pourquoi pas je suis tout ouïe
et en ce moment ça va être compliqué
mais eric se trimballe bien avec des
bouquins phil brown pourquoi pas finie
la différence est que instagram ne
pouvait contrôler c'est vous qui êtes au
compteur que des danseuses d'aller sur
un autre média fait montre forcément ce
qu'on va montrer et oui c'est vrai moi
je pensais alors là vous allez rire
c'est plus une pudeur à l'intérieur
juste mais personnel à l'intérieur à
l'intérieur voyez on peut penser qu'on
est en bas et ben moi j'ai tout le temps
en basket en en pantalon on est très
discrète sur comment on est très
différente de ce qu'on monte sur les
réseaux par rapport à la fin nous
personnellement nos vraies personnes et
je pense que c'est ça qui est d'accepter
aussi nos parents qui nous vend en
maillot de bain mois pour moi vous êtes
des playmates moderne comme ces femmes
qui faisaient des photos de charme dans
les magazines type playboy
eh bien ce sont nos plémet d'aujourd'hui
évidemment moi je me relève selon pas
dans votre marque parce que évidemment
j'ai pris le voilà je veux manger la
ménopause tout ça ça va prendre du poids
moi je vais vous dire moi c'est quelque
chose qui me dépasse complètement de
montrer votre popotin sur instagram et
où d'ailleurs il ya une photo sur votre
instagram qui m'a fait mourir de rire
vous dit joyeux noël et la photo c'est
votre cul cul merci moi c'est ce qu'on
s'en fait du sapin je suis ravi et pas
très vite ou si vous voulez faire
plaisir
[Applaudissements]